I'm curious about the bachelor tears
that we're gonna see this season there
is man cry there's lots of man cried
it's not a good season unless you have
man cry because men aren't good at
crying I like it when there's that
indecision of a guy like do I go for it
I really cry Jojo I need any tears from
her yeah Jojo Jojo is she was really
good at kind of giving herself up to
this whole thing and just going for it
and it's a rocky ride do you anticipate
that Jojo will find love this season
that is my goal my dream I mean top to
bottom our entire staff loved Jojo
working with her was a dream I want this
to work we almost try too hard for
people like that because you want it to
work for him so bad
it worked for Ben and I think fingers
crossed it's gonna work for Jojo - Chris
hairs ain't talked all things
Bachelorette and live with Kelly with us
at 102.7 kiss FM's Wango Tango concert
on Saturday would you ever let your kids
do the bachelor or bachelorette when
they're of age you know I decided is I
would like to retire very soon my son
and my daughter it's like Hunger Games
they're vying for my job yeah I would
like for one of them to take over soon
retire soon does that mean that you're
gonna possibly potentially take over the
kellian - I want to retire like I want
to quit any more television you're out
of the business my kids are gonna work
for me and send me their checks and I'm
just gonna move to an island you don't
want to throw your name though in the
live with Kelly it's the same network
it's ABC disney it's a great show it
really is a great gig it might be the
best gig next to hosting Who Wants to Be
a Millionaire it might be the best
daytime gig there is it really I've
hosted with Kelly she's a phenomenal
talent hopefully I'll go in and co-host
with her just because I love Kelly and I
love doing it and it's a fun show but I
have nine other jobs to do right now no
if they if they offered it to you never
see never had to my mom always said